taste buds they come to the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two fools going to
fight but only one food can be right
tast
buds hey Tasties welcome to
T
buds uh quickly Joey Rose's San Janeiro
Festival is going on the feast or the
Sano Feast Sano Festival Festival I know
it is Feast I keep call up the Fest it's
Feast Feast right yeah these are
t-shirts we're selling I saw them online
and I was like well clearly you're
definitely going to bring one in for me
I didn't I'm sorry I'll bring you I'll
get you guys t-shirts what's the what's
the tag on that so Dan keep it this was
a collab with friends from New York I
love it friends from New York are
awesome it's my friend Heidi's thing uh
she throws all these events and parties
and stuff in New York and they're
awesome I I've actually invited you once
or twice to when I was going she's like
it'll be like she'll do a thing and it's
like Stretch Armstrong as DJ I love it I
met Mike D at one of her parties
really cool by the way BC boys square
square
is it's nuts and then they were there
giving a thank you speech and I was like
man I could have been there like the two
like the be boys have escaped me my
whole life I've been I've orbited them
and I've seen them and everything but
and I know of somebody who knows
somebody but like I've never met them
they're on a very very very short list
of people that I would really want to
meet and probably be a little nervous to
meet he was I have a video somewhere
Paul was with me and took a video of me
meeting him like from across the room
cuz I was like all excited when I saw
him Mike no Mike D yeah it was at Pier
17 or whatever the outdoor yeah like two
summers ago and like I saw him and I was
like Dude That's Mike D and I was like I
I got to I got to I got to meet him I
got to say hi he was just hanging by the
DJ booth like just like just hanging out
yeah yeah like just like noding his head
and I went
over and I was just like I'm so sorry so
there's a video of me you can't hear
anything I'm sorry yeah I'm so sorry to
bother you don't be that guy bro yeah
and I go dude I'm so sorry to bother you
but I'm going to yeah I go I I you know
I was
like I don't know what else to say to
you dude but I can't even begin to tell
you how much of a part of my life you
are and and I was like you're a legend
dude I just had to shake your hand and
he was he was really he smile like very
genuinely smile that I had to shake your
hand I would have been like you don't
have to shake
my it was it was amidst Co I think it
was like summer it was the summer after
the it was like when they let us out it
was like that summer why didn't I then
why didn't I know this when it happened
you're keeping or maybe it was the
following summer but it was between
lockdowns you were allowed out memory
you wouldn't relay that to me that you
met Mike D I probably did relay it to
you I don't think you did I also have
Mike D design find a wallpaper with a
company and um that wallpaper is in the
my stairwell of my home oh yeah yeah
yeah that's right I forgot
aboutall the um but anyway so this this
t-shirt we we made with friends from New
York uh as a collab for the feast the
back I don't know if you can see it
friends feasting from New York yeah so
so we both both uh crews are repped on
either side Joey Rose is on the front FR
on the back and feast on the back but
what is the tag please what do you mean
what's the tag on the inside of that
shirt I need to know what the tag says
on the inside of that material well sure
I don't understand what you're saying
the Brandon the material please oh I I
tore it out I don't
know why why do you why you ask you have
no idea what it was I could get you that
information well I just cuz there's
certain shirts I I refuse to wear they
just don't know what they do in the BR
it's a it's a nice little shirt it's a
quality shirt I find
you know it'll
I what stand up stand up just put pull
it down let me just see how it fits what
size is
that large what what is
this I don't like it why you not say you
don't like it as I'm trying to sell the
shirt shirt no I love the shirt the
shirt's amazing for me for my body for
my type okay I don't like it I have an
experience with t-shirts I have a
thousand t-shirts you wear a blend tea I
see what you wear you like Blend or no
blend I don't care if it's not or not a
blend I just need to know that that
company understands how to cut a garment
and sew it I like this shirt for the the
the the quality of the shirt I like
because this is the kind of uh black tea
yeah that will age well I like a chunky
or black tea cuz as you wash it it
starts to get that fade whatever I don't
like a blend tea that much because it
looks it looks brand new for all time
until the day it literally just falls
apart I actually fully agree with you
but the thing I don't like about not
that it's that that type of tea but like
I just don't love a big boxy cut with a
wide neck I'm not saying that's what you
have right I'm just saying I hope that's
not that when I try it on because I've
gotten teas that I I I would want to
marry them that's how much I like what's
on them and then I don't wear them
because maybe instead of fearing the
worst with your dear friend SLP partner
slash love let's be honest uh t-shirt
you hope for the best yeah and that's
something I'm working on because
I I I Feer the worst in every aspect of
my entire life I you know my therapist
told me last week and it blew my mind or
as you would say balls off that's how
you say
it I was talking about all this with him
and I said why I I go and dude I swear
to God like a light switch he said this
and immediately everything shifted I'm
excited I go everything on paper in my
life is good and all I can do is focus
on what the problem is meaning no
meaning those words came out of my my
mouth last night to my lady and I said
to him and I said I said there's no
situation in my life that I'm in where
I'm not the ultimate person in it like I
there I don't have any situation where I
can turn to the o to another guy above
me and go well that's his problem sure
you know I'm only I'm like every
business everything I'm involved in it's
a it's my own thing sword which I'm
lucky about sure but sometimes you're
like I really wish there was a
supervisor that had to deal with this
right so and I said and the anxiety and
I said even with like trying to purchase
a home I'm not married I'm doing it all
by myself everything has to be taken on
and absorbed by me even though in some
scenarios like this when I have a
partner where we both have to take it on
but still you're still best case
scenario shoulder toh shoulder with the
other guy that also has to take out
right what saying and he said I have
never heard it phrased this way I was
like holy he goes I can't wait to
hear what bonmont you're about to drop
he goes you need to start accepting the
chore of seeing what is good and all you
have that is the challenge yeah he goes
because it is a challenge and it is very
hard to do it's really easy to just
focus on the bad stuff and crumble and
be anxious and whatever he goes take on
the chore of what is positive and
recognizing that and I was like holy
like it just immediately like light
bulb went off oh it's work I have to see
it as work isn't a perspective amazing
it's crazy I watched uh have you seen
stuts yet on Netflix I started watching
it you know what I didn't like where the
reason I didn't finish it I I shouldn't
say didn't like it well I didn't finish
it I felt like it was at least in the
beginning and maybe I should have sat it
out I felt like it was way more about
Jonah Hill than it was about the guy and
I was like I don't understand why I'm
watching Jonah Hill speak on camera
look let me tell I get that he can sell
it because he's a big name but well let
me tell you let me tell you so I I I I
started to watch it a bit back and I
just watched a little bit of it and I
got a sense of it but I didn't finish it
either something kept telling me to go
back to it cuz was intriguing but for
whatever reason just like anything else
I'm busy and I if something doesn't hook
me hook me so I went back to it the
other day it's
tremendous it is absolutely tremendous
so much so I'm not even joking around
with you so much so so it first of all
the guy Phil stuts is his his
psychologist psychiatrist I always mix
up the two um he's he's been in this
business a long time and he's unique and
unorthodox in the way that he approaches
this kind of thing and it's all about
perspective like he doesn't say anything
throughout this dock that I've never
heard before or the sentiment of it or
the idea of it but the way that he
frames these things just like that is
completely new to anything I've heard
before and with my brain the way it
works he makes it like something
actionable and something that you have
to work like it it's hard to explain but
what you just said how he that happened
like 20 times in this and he broke down
his stuff into like a method and he made
his own method and he has like you know
he calls this thing this and this thing
this and he tells you like what to work
on and how to work on it and why and he
gives you these things called tools
wherein as when you're in a moment at a
Crossroads with something that we
normally have a lot of issues with he
gives you these ways these exercises to
do in that exact moment to handle the
situation and to to move forward from it
and none of it's like BS it's all it was
all like
really really I absor and I watched it
and I was like GE and halfway through I
was like I should be taking notes I
really should because I want to take
everything away that he's saying and it
was a lot um he later says I've only
imparted 10% of what I teach in this doc
but I've decided that just like therapy
like literally like it's about an hour
and a half at least once a week I'm
going to watch at least 45 minutes I'm
going to W I'm going to keep watching it
I want to like start to
absorb absorb bit that way and cuz cuz
also as he's doing it I'm thinking of
things that I would be in there so
talking about and saying and applying it
to myself and I'm like oh wow and I'm
like you know what dude this was more
I've seen some therapists for six months
and watching that for 90 minutes was
more I'll go back to it I'll go back to
it the uh I'll go back to it because
that's you know what you just
said
perspective also too like wording
phrasing there's there's such wisdom in
Simplicity you know and
people we we forget that that's why
there's like children's books like I
just bought because I saw a clip of a
guy he was like a I think he was like a
piece of yeah was I was on
Instagram the guy was like a fighter or
something I don't know he was you know
he might have been a an agent a real
estate I don't remember what the guy did
but he was quoting this children's book
that's called like the the boy the The
Boy The Mule the horse and the something
I I bought it I bought the book because
the quote I was like holy I bought
the book and I read it and it's a
children's book basically I mean the the
the be the far word says it's not meant
just for children it's meant for
everybody but it's very much designed
like in the way like The Giving Tree or
something like that but there's a great
line in it where they talk about a man
somebody asks a man is the glass is your
glass half anti or half full and he says
I'm not sure I'm just a appreciative
that I have a glass and I'm like that's
so
simple and it like rocked me there's a
Woody Allen movie where like a hurricane
like a hurricane there's a Woody Allen
movie where he says he tells a joke oh
he does a joke guys goes to the doctor
and says it hurts when I do this doctor
says then don't do it he goes there's
great wisdom in jokes there's more
insight into most jokes than there is
from the world's greatest philosophers
and again it's simplic it's like that
goofy it boils down a truth of life
which is like if something is hurting
you stop doing it you know what I mean
yeah and that's such a duh moment but
like somebody says it to you like that
that directly you go absolutely oh yeah
you're right and in it like he he's he
asks Jonah questions Jonah's really
interviewing him to put out his methods
to the world because it helped him and
Jonah keeps pushing back and go I'm not
going to talk about that cuz it's about
you not me and I don't want to do that
happens again happens again and then the
the stuts is like just like well you
know what like I really would appreciate
it if you did because by you doing that
will allow me to open up and and get
further in this like he keeps pushing
him to do it and then finally like
there's a really interesting thing that
happens halfway through where I don't
want to give it away but like kind of
Jonah comes clean about something and
like in in relation to them filming and
like completely like resets everything
and it was really cool and and then
Jonah start to speak and honestly it it
doesn't feel like it's all about him it
actually just feels like you're watching
this and also what Jonah is you going
extremely relatable right so it's not
even like you know you it's not like
you're listening to his problems per se
okay fair enough yeah and uh well well
we were talking before by the way you
can get these shirts by the time this
airs the San Jan n is is over where can
we get him baby but as of this recording
we won week in one first week was a
great success man great time thank you
to gelo and gr for for having us do the
popup uh but you can get these at Joey
roses uh you know we did a limited run
so whatever's left is available at Joey
roses and pimp if you could put the link
there's going to be a website you can
get them from too and you set yourself
aside in XL for me and I'll give you the
money for I'm happy to support XL yeah
really no wow no why Mystic oh no I'm an
Excel I'm kidding I'm
joking that's nice you had a nice
conversation about therapy and
perspective from my perspective you're
not an
EXL I am now I'm just kidding you look
great you you've you've been losing some
don't go back on I'm very serious you've
you've you've been doing something what
are you doing I'm down 33 lbs over the
course of since my since my heaviest
what are you doing like a year ago what
have you been doing just eating better
no exercise just food not just yet but I
am about to start exercising but no just
food yeah I I got a long way to go be
honest I I'd love I'd love to lose at
least another 30 before I film the
special are you going ke like keto or
you just just you're not you're just
like no I'm just not eating like an
idiot less eating better yeah good um
yeah so I have a lot long ways to go but
I'll just say this real quick cuz you
didn't hear this but I would like to say
it within the app um the the tickets for
my special they went on sale last week
that's December 2nd at the vicin Chicago
everyone supported me tremendously and
pretty much they sold out great um right
right away so what we're doing is we're
adding one more night only the day
before Friday December 1st we're adding
two more shows I'm not adding any more
after that um the tickets have only been
on sale a few days and they already sold
out so we're going to try to sell these
other ones out and I'm going to try to
do four shows over two nights so they're
on sale right now when this comes out
savc comedy.com and just one other quick
thing is just because people will ask it
doesn't matter what show you're at or
what ticket you have I'm choosing one
person that is in attendance at these
four shows and I'm going to fly them
into New York put them up in a hotel and
bring them on a out of imp practical
joker so all you got to do is buy a
ticket and be there you and a plus one
will get that that's still up for grabs
on the new night and uh yeah so thank
you guys just just so so much I was
shocked out yeah it's fantastic uh
congrats thanks baby thank you and again
I'm hoping to get there for the night of
the second oh yeah you did mention that
but we didn't get into it yeah let's get
into it off camera but yeah I'm hoping
to make that happen oh will you let me
know that'd be amazing of course yeah
well I'm already going to be on the road
so it's just a matter of routing if it
makes sense you know it's bat to
get from one you know whatever anyway um
we um guys we used to have a partner
named Ray Khan that we haven't seen in a
bit and it's back and we are super super
excited okay it's the time of the year
with stuff's changing the vibe is
changing we're getting cozy holidays are
coming up and it's rayon's anniversary
that's the holiday I'm talking about oh
you thought I meant like the fall
holidays no you're thinking do you mean
Halloween HH I told you let me ask you
this does Halloween also give you 20 to
40% off premium Electronics no they
don't then listen up cuz rayon's
celebrating their anniversary and you
don't want to miss a sale you might have
heard us mention raycon sale before
they're turning six they've really made
a name for themselves in the premium
audio space as a matter of fact that's
my reminder to buy a bunch of stuff from
raycon um this past year they expanded
their entire business with the
introduction of raycon home and raycon
power Tech so needless to say there is a
lot to celebrate okay everyday earbuds
are known for delivering high quality
audio and thoughtful features like 32
battery uh 32h hour battery life and
perfect in your fit for all day wear and
comfort uh all this at half the price of
other premium Brands so they have that
but they've expanded to so much more and
they have over
78,000 festar reviews you don't want to
miss out on anniversary sale what are
you going to do you're not going to wait
till the seven right get in on it now
celebrate raycon turning six with their
biggest sale of the Year going on right
now hurry now to buy
raycon.com taste Buds and use code
birthday to get 20 to 40% off sitewide
okay that's code birthday at by raycon
Ry n.com tastebuds to score 20 to 40%
off by raycon.com tastebuds I got to
tell you something I was going to go see
Billy Jill's residency at the Garden for
the fourth time and I've usually uh
ordered my tickets six months in advance
but uh at the last minute a buddy of
mine I realized had never seen him we
were going to go and I was like you know
what I got the game time app this will
be perfect I went online the night
before and I bought uh Billy Joel
tickets at Madison Square Garden on the
game time app and I even got to send him
a picture of where we were sitting
because they show you exactly where you
are it takes two clicks to do this thing
and it gets sent right to your phone so
when we went I wasn't like online at the
Garden like shuffling through emails
looking for some type of barcode uh I
really like game time uh it's an app
that gives you the best prices for last
minute tickets guaranteed and it's not
just music it's Sports it's uh comedy
hello it's Broadway hello it's movies
hello all that kind of stuff last minute
tickets they got Flash Deals they got
Zone deals and their lowest price
guarantee which is pretty cool because
basically what happens is if you find
the same SE uh tickets in a section and
row the same section Row for Less game
time credit you that
110% of the difference uh all your price
totals are shown upfront so you know
what you're getting there are no hidden
fees uh I really like game time take the
guest work out of buying tickets with
Game Time download the game time app
today create an account and use the code
tastebuds for $20 off your first
purchase terms apply again create an
account and redeem code taste buds t a s
bus for $20 off download game time today
last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed folks CH to Rosa here I got
some live dates coming up I'd like to
tell you about why not uh I'm doing a
special show on November 9th at the KGB
Bar New York City as part of the New
York Comedy Festival the show's called
selected readings where I'm going to be
reading excerpts from my audio book The
Penthouse papers released on uh a
special thing records and I'm also going
to be reading some other stuff I've had
published over the years I'm looking
forward to that then I'm hitting the big
open road getting out of my own town
where I live and I'm coming to you with
what I Never Promised You a Rose Garden
live the new hour very proud of this
show no November 11th hit in
Philadelphia PA theater of the Living
Arts November 17th Pittsburgh PA at
bottle rocket Social Hall November 18th
Buffalo New York theater at senica 1 the
30th of November Denver Colorado at the
summit December 1st Phoenix Arizona at
the Crescent Ballroom and December 3rd
Salt Lake City Utah at the soundwell
folks we're adding dates all the time
but for these dates and ones we might
add later you can go to joa.com for
Ticket links and show information and of
course if you are in New York City and
you want to check out my establishment
Joey roses come on down we're open 7
days a week 11:30 a.m. every day we open
those doors for affordable booze and
delicious affordable sandwiches Joey
roses nc.com what's up guys real quick
tour dates are on sale right now at
salvano comedy.com uh there's tons of
cities up there tomorrow night if you're
watching us right now on hey bab
tomorrow night I am in Bowling Green
Kentucky on Friday Cincinnati on
Saturday and Toledo on Sunday there's
still some tickets available so get
those uh following that we're going to
be in wils Bear Pennsylvania and
Wilmington Delaware then we're do in mon
Savannah and Athens Georgia and so on
and so forth there's a big Illinois run
in November leading up to my comedy
special at the Vick in Chicago on
December 1st and 2nd the second sold out
as you guys I hopefully know uh and so
we added two shows on the first all will
be taped and all if you have a ticket to
any of those shows you'll be eligible to
win uh a flight hotel and trip to the
set of Impractical Jokers I'm choosing
one ticket out of those four shows uh
December 1st is still on sale right now
but it's going fast savalan comedy.com
hope to see you guys on the road oh and
I did the first show my
tour Saturday in avanel avanel New
Jersey yeah packed house I can't thank
aanal Performing Art Center and the
audience that came out to that thing
enough
it was such an amazing way to start it
was so killer it was so killer I
recorded that just Caitlyn ree who's
really funny and a good friend she was
opens for me a lot she was there she I
just had to recorded on my iPhone on her
iPhone so I could just encour yeah
encouraging yeah I I I know I'm going to
this run now that I'm doing of this hour
is now the this is the honing of okay
this is going to end up being how I
shoot it okay uh
but it was amazing it was one of the
best times I've ever had doing this hour
it was such a way to kick the tour off
crowd was oh they were
amazing got good news going on pimpy
everybody got good news Good Vibes today
man yeah pimp you want to you know okay
got it got it no but I'm just I didn't
think I was just saying yeah good but
taste taste buds was in effect obviously
and uh it's funny man because there's a
part in the show now where I
say I talk about getting trolled
and uh you know I tell a bunch of
stories we're getting trolled and I and
I started by saying I go guys I've been
doing comedy for 23 years I've pissed
off a lot of people I don't know what it
is it's something about my face people
just don't like me right and uh and I I
say to the crowd sometimes I'm like well
he didn't like you yeah I say to the
crowd I go I know there's a lot of taste
buds fans here I go I saw what you said
about me in the
beginning why isn't it cute I always
told you you'll win over yeah why is he
with this guy now you want to Rite to me
and go you know I hated your guts now I
like you as if that's a
compliment but it got that got a huge
Pop I was really happy that they thought
that was funny but anyway it was by I
don't think I realize that the people
you're getting over there are going uh
lukewarm on me and coming to going over
here I noticed that too I know it's
real it's always a price to pay nothing
could just ever be easy good stuff man
okay good we were talking speaking of
perspective so we had a we you were
telling me a we had a fire at
everybody's fine it was a small fire but
we did have a fire at Joey roses we had
to stay closed yesterday to deal with it
uh we're back open today so you know but
but there's still there're still it it
was a fire fire is any way you slice
what caught on fire I don't have all the
full details I know we had people there
looking into it insurance and all that
stuff was there today is it a curtain a
wall a sandwich I I I believe no no
there was a there was a wall area where
I I saw pictures of what where damage
occurred or whatever
and no no curtains c malfunction or mal
I'm waiting to get the final you know
what I don't want to I don't want to
speculate but I'm I'm waiting to get the
final but yeah obviously it was
something went wrong you know and and
we're trying to figure out exactly how
it was caused yesterday that was one of
the things you have to do is you have to
shut we to shut the bar down turn the
electricity off shut down Mike yeah yeah
shut shut down Mike we so
anyway everybody's
okay Jesus Christ you're just like
you're just like what else is going to I
was just in the room for those of you at
home pimping sound guys the business is
on fire right now we did yeah we did all
our ads Sal you should have done a promo
right in front of the fire real quick
like just turned on a selfie like guys
Joey Rose is on fire get it's hot hot
hot yeah it's playing Buster Point diers
yeah I was in the other room Salon
pimped all the ads without me cuz I was
on the phone and I came back in and they
were like you guys were all like we're
so sorry dude is everything okay with
the fire I'm like oh that had nothing to
do with the fire that was another whole
thing that is in another part of my life
that's also a
problem it just never stopped and you
were like I can relate and then you
started to tell me a story and I said
save it for the air please your bar when
you had a bar what happened a a literal
van drove through it while we were
open wait I shouldn't laugh was anybody
hurt yeah oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm not
laughing at that I don't think there was
no serious injuries but they went flying
the the van came through literally
through the front wall and hit like the
front like two boots that were on the
wall and people were in those boots and
they just like I think somebody ran and
jumped and then the other guys just got
thrown across the room and the van went
all the way in by the way that's the
that was my second job that a van drove
through the Wallen I also worked at a
convenience store in high high school
and a little bit of college and a park
car just drove right through to like
through five aisles just hit hit the gas
jumped no they were in park I guess hit
the gas that they were reversing just
went went forward broke through brick
glass drove through four or five aisles
both times we have on a security camera
on both who reverses at that velocity no
they went forward no I'm saying that
they were jumping forward thinking they
were reversed with enough speed to crash
them it's like who's hitting reverse you
know I think happened you ever see this
phenomenon this is my favorite fail
online it's a motorcycle fail when
people get on and they they try to they
go and it goes underneath them because
they go like that and they don't realize
how fast it's going and then their
Instinct goes like that and it just goes
and they just go out of control and it
you know what I think that they were
probably looking behind them and then
they went to go push reverse and when it
went forward they were like kind of
thrown and this is me
speculating uh and then they went
through I had a when I lived in La I
bought a an electric uh like a
rechargeable
scooter because I didn't realize I this
is a true story I did I would love to
see you whipping down the street in a
scooter dude I loved it I love to see it
that's when you drank your Ros right oh
yeah big Ros days scooter Ros the uh
Helmet or no helmet always helmet oh
yeah oh even more I want to see it just
like I could pick you full motorcycle
like full I just pick you like a m one
of those mesh backpacks with like two
bottles of Rosé in it like a full helmet
just speeding down the street little
basket like yelling at people
like I uh no I bought it because my
license expired you probably tried to do
tricks every once in a while I didn't
realize my license was going to expire
and I remember I was in um you wait you
mean your license for for driving so you
got you so you had no license D I was in
Portland Oregon doing shows I was flying
back from Portland literally on my
birthday and I looked and realized my
license was expiring that was the last
day of my license and I was like oh
Jesus Christ I never looked cuz I still
had my New York license so whatever
notice I got to say you got to re up it
went it didn't get it right and
uh and I was and I didn't have a license
and I was like when you're license
expires at least in California you have
to go through the whole thing again you
have to take the test everything like
you can't just you had to you so so I
was like God I didn't feel like it right
so I got I went to a place it was a
motorized scooter yeah yeah and I said
what can I drive what am I allowed to
drive in here that you don't need a
license and the guy goes this scooter I
have a question so I bought the scoo was
it one of those ones where you see and
you're always like how'd that kid get
that they have like real wheels and it
runs on gas like I know like he
definitely put that together himself or
was it like the razor one that you plug
in and it's like a sit down a sit down
yeah it was a sit down two wheel like it
was like a scooter like a real you know
that one the first one oh the deluxe
velocity oh that's like a moped yeah or
or I'm sorry pimp go over to
ta49 that one that's a moped was like
that yeah yeah you know what I thought
the scooter is that oh sorry yeah it was
a moped scooter is when you step
yeah a moped so where is it now okay so
I had this thing yeah yeah and it was
like 7 800 bucks they're they're way I
mean for what it is it's pretty cheap
you know like it's a God don't get it on
the expressway or anything you're not
allowed yeah it's street legal but you
can't take it on the expressway caps at
30 or 35 miles per hour so I just picted
you race down the street with a shirt
that says street legal on it oh that's
good that's good helmet maybe you got
the helmet on and like the D draws with
and the roses are up
here Ros are up on the like the you wear
one of those beer helmets with roses in
I'm drinking it so dude scoo scoot
scooting is not a crime I drove that
thing for like a month maybe two months
and then I was talking to somebody I go
yeah it's great dude you don't even need
a driver's license I was like I don't
even care that I don't have a license
anymore I used to use this thing
everywhere it's charge rechargeable it's
like you know and he goes what are you
talking about he goes you you're not
allowed to drive those driver's license
I was like yes you are and he goes no
you're not no look it up so I did and it
was like you are absolutely not allowed
to operate with us so I went back to the
store and I yelled at the guy and he
gave me a full
refund after months of using it yeah
that's awesome yeah cuz I go dude I go
dude do you realize I could literally
have gone to jail you assured me I
didn't need a license for this what was
his response he was like well I don't
know about and I go no there's nothing
to not know about here's what you said
and here's what the law is and I showed
it to him and he was like all right
we'll give you a refund brought the law
in yeah wow yeah and that was it I got a
refund and then I went and got my
license he gave you a full refund on a
did you buy a new I used
new you had it for two months you were
scooting around it might have only been
a month how long you sco around town how
long were you scooting around was at
least a full month a month probably was
more like two months nearly daily yeah
and I caught a guy stealing it twice
two times I caught a guy stealing it no
different guy you said I you said I
caught a guy stealing it twice oh the
different guy two times I caught guys
stealing what's up with you when your
bike got robbed too crazy they dude
these guys I would take the battery you
can't have nothing nice you can't have a
nice scooter and I had it parked on in
my private driveway and a guy walked on
just picked it up wheels were locked
Wheels were locked and he piced cuz
that's like you know an anti- theft
thing picked it up and was like just
dragging it standing up you heard him
out the window you happen to be pulling
up coming out of the house how'd you
find I think I just saw him doing it I
think I just like came home to find this
guy by chance okay what happened how did
this unfold like wait what are you doing
oh oh you know it's a crazy
homeless guy and he like walks off and
you're like what am I going to do fight
the guy I was in a store I was in shout
out to whalebone I was in the whalebone
store uh big shout outs on at B on bleer
and Soho and I was in there right and
some guy comes in and he has his luggage
with him and he's like I'm going to take
a couple I'm going to look take a quick
look over here he leaves the luggage
right outside the the front door I
didn't hear the guy say that so then
we're I'm in the store and some guy
opens the door he goes oh he goes he
goes is this anyone is this your luggage
I was like no it's not my luggage he
goes that's not your luggage I go he
goes no he goes okay he opens the
luggage and just starts he just walks
away he starts crossing the street all
of a sudden the other guy runs from the
back runs out he goes whoa whoa whoa
whoa the guy's halfway across the street
rolling his luggage he goes what are you
doing what are you doing that's mine he
goes to grab and the guy won't give it
to him he goes it's my luggage let go
it's my lug luggage he he goes what the
hell you he Yanks out he goes what the
hell are you doing it's my luggage and
the guy I guess he was like I don't know
home I don't know if he was homeless or
just and he goes he he's in the middle
of the intersection he goes how was I
supposed to know it's your
luggage it's a great response and the
guy looked at him like and then just
walked away and we were like you know
it's not yours yeah that's a great
response it was great we were crack it
up yeah that's like a mind trick
response where you're like wait well
you're not supposed wait a wait wait a
minute so so you were just the same you
were like well guy guy come on I got you
you weren't just like no I was just like
what are you doing that's not yours
that's my you know and then another time
same same type of
thing the other time I think the my
neighbor caught the guy and sent me a
picture like just so you know this
happen so the one you returned also had
two attempted robberies on it plus
almost two months of scooting around
yeah and the guy must have been scared
then cuz for him to be like he has a
full refund on a new scooter that that
Dee well cuz I said to him I go dude you
I could have gone to literally gone to
jail and I could have been fine the fine
was like 50 Grand or at that point it
was Z word against his I'm surprised he
no that's why I said I showed him the
law like he could have been like I
didn't sell him that it was the owner of
the shop there he was there with
salespeople it was a you know it's a
niche kind of shop it's not like you're
at a dealership I also think you're
gifted at getting a refund I am I will
thank you I appre I actually appreciate
that I actually I am pretty gifted at I
am pretty good at like I think that's a
TV show you get people their refunds oh
yeah it's a it's at least a segment on
something it's just should be a Daily
Show segment well let me let me let me
tell you right now I wrote to Uber the
other day remember when the guy screwed
me I wrote to them I said listen this is
what happened and if you don't
appropriately um refund me I you could
look at my my record with Uber I've
spent I spent a ton of money on Uber
tons right I said I will I will not I
will switch I will not use your platform
they wrote back hey we got your message
we're so sorry that happened we'd like
to offer you a $5 credit a $5 credit so
then I wrote back I said listen I said I
told you that if you didn't respond
appropriately you would lose my business
I've been I've been using by the way
that response is an automated response
that's not a human being so it said
right so I said that I go I don't even
know what this is I said but I told you
I said I would like this I would like
this escalated to the
absolute highest level uh title that you
can you know send it to but I'm just
just so they know that I'm leaving and I
said I'm I told you I would switch I'm
switching you'll never see my you'll
never see it again unless you and then
they wrote me back again and just said
you have reached just so you know you
have reached the highest level of we are
you are talking now to the highest level
of person who can talk about this um let
us know if we can do anything else for
you like not like whatever so I just I
mean I I took lift today yeah I I I
deleted it's wild I deleted Uber and and
I took and I'm now I'm starting to take
lift I got into a thing with a
guy involving something I'm doing I'm
trying to keep it vague first thing or
the second thing but the guy you know
word was given conf you know uh a
confirmation was
given that something would be a certain
way and it turned out it wasn't you know
I have no idea what you're talking about
right now good I don't want anybody to
know it's it's a little less this I was
I was more or less guaranteed a price on
something oh and then the price The
price came back different yeah and I
said on Friday to the guy the dude I I
went so hard at the first guy his boss
called me I went so hard at her her boss
called me and her boss called me and he
goes I think we got a little
misunderstanding here and I go I'm going
to stop copy right there and I'm going
to save you a lot of time and he starts
going Joe Joe Joe and I go do not talk
to me like that and he goes then you
don't talk to me like that I go no I do
because you guys are the ones playing
around not me so don't waste my time
with explanations I've heard all the
explanation we went through the whole
thing and he goes well what I want to
help what can I do to help I go give me
the number you assured me I would
receive and he goes I can't do that and
I go then I don't understand what you're
definition of the word help is and he
goes okay well call me if you need
anything uh it's unreal it means nothing
the word means nothing anymore we want
to accommodate we want to help we won't
do anything to change any of it but we
want
to it's just God I hate everything so
much I feel like in in that in that
capacity when you're dealing with that
any type of institution or business or
organization that is either a monopoly
or really has you buy the nuts uh
Airlines whatever I feel like Game of
Life we should do it Monopoly it's the
game of life I feel like we should we
should all Checkers not chess exactly I
I think that we should all petition and
try to get this uh bill turned into a
law whatever the hell it's you do
whereas like wherein as if someone in
that capacity gets caught almost like a
little Scarlet Letter you get to like
tattoo on their face something like what
they did and so then meanwhile you know
so you come see a guy coming on the
street his face is all tatted up he'll
never work in any IND well there was
there was like 5 Seconds that's reason
yeah but here's the thing there was like
a 5c period where that existed and it
existed through online reviews for 5
seconds online reviews were just they
were fair and you and it's been ruined
now because people just use them as
Weapons now they've weaponized it right
so now we don't even you could I could
find a restaurant at this point the
rating could be 1.3 I'm still going to
roll the dice cuz I'm like God these
people might be knows never
know you know what I mean or or vice
versa something can have a 5.0 perfect
rating and I'm still like I don't know
if I trust it well I I I had to learn to
just just take a leap of faith because
what I'll do is like at a for a hotel or
even something on Amazon I'll be like
all right 40,000 reviews it's like you
know 4.5 stars and I'll go look like let
me just take a look at the negative
reviews you ever do review math and it's
like the negative review is like oh I'm
not that's terrible I'm not doing this
do you ever do review math
meaning I do this all the time like
especially on Amazon I'll be like
well this version of the product has an
85% five star you know but they've only
got 7,000 votes this one's got a oh yeah
this one's got a
78 new on the reviews some new on the
block with five stars is not going
nowhere with me I I need I need I need a
I need I need reviews man I need a
history we got a battle I think yeah
what is it we're continuing the French
fry tournament now we got winners of the
last french fry tournament we did uh
curly won right curly versus crinkle
curly be crinkle and traditional beat
sweet potato yeah blew the balls off of
it so right now curly and and and
traditional head head and and and it's
perfect so far because you repped curly
and I rep traditional so right now we've
each got a contender going into the
semi-finals now you got four other
players in the game four other players
we got two battles today steak versus
waffle and shoestring versus tater tot
let's begin with steak versus waffle
and time to b a t t l e butts all right
Sal team steak fry I am team waffle fry
I want to begin by
saying I don't understand why you keep
insisting that waffle fries in in our
private conversations when we're alone
at night when it's just you and me and
the whole world is shut out yeah why do
you keep insisting that the waffle fres
is the same as the curly fries the
reason I do that that's the reason I do
that is cuz it
is in what sense you you I've had a
seasoned waffle fry I've also had a
seasoned traditional
fry but but I've also had unseasoned
waffle fries to Great Lengths much more
than I've had seasoned waffle fries and
I don't understand why you you keep
saying the these are first waffle fry I
had that wasn't seasoned was the place
you was what was the place you called
that the place I called it Chick-fil-A
yeah that's waffle major North American
waffle fry yeah they only serve waffle
fries they don't even give you an option
can I just say something and this might
be unpopular opinion
Chick-fil-A I don't care about the you
know they in the news politics let's
just talk about the food before we knew
anything about anything I don't give a
about that Chick-fil-A really I was
very impressed with a chain chicken
grilled chicken sandwich it was Juicy
and Delicious I will tell you something
right now I think their fries are not
good they are not they are they are just
not they are I mean you talk about you
know I mean I they're not even in the
same league as a sandwich like the Fry
is disag plain and dry and I I will say
this I've had bad batches of Chick-fil-A
fries as I've had bad batches of every
place's fries when it's done right and
when they are good I love the
Chick-fil-A fry I get
excited first of all it's a very
Chick-fil-A uh they do take a very they
Implement their Christian approach into
the menu you know so this is God's law
you'll get waffle fry and that's it you
we're not giving you choices here you
pray to one God and our God is the
waffle fry I mean I I I don't know how
you do something so well the other thing
dude Chick-fil-A that is such a
wonderful treat at Chick-fil-A getting
those waffle fries with that amazing
chicken sandwich I put the fries onto
the sandwich sometimes and the and the
circumference of the fry the surface
area of the fry it it works per it's a
nice stacking fry that's that's good for
that but I will say if you if you
specified Chick-fil-A waffle on this I I
think you would get demolished I think
you no that's just no cuz o you know we
talked last week about you know this the
Store br frozen fries that you cook at
home are always going to be a lower
quality but but I will say out of all
those Store br freezer aisle fries the
orid waffle fry is one that often does
comes out well here's why I like the
waffle fry against a curly even I know
it's not battling curly again the
surface area of a waffle fry a waffle
fry is designed in a way where it is
able to cook evenly I've never had an
unevenly cooked waffle fry now I've had
waffle fries that were overdone or
underdone but I've never had an unevenly
cooked waffle fry and even with
traditional fries sometimes they're
they're you you get a weird
mixture uh in
temperatures the waffle fry is a great
treat by the way too and I'll say this
and I'll throw to you if you ever get
french fry nachos someplace which some
places will do them like a loaded a
loaded it's it's basically instead of
tortilla chips it's fries they use
waffle fries nine times out of 10 and oh
my god dude you get a waffle fry with
with some of Sada and melted cheese and
c I mean you have to you have to pull me
away from it you have to pull me away
from it it's a food that I need you to
keep away from me so I don't kill myself
by eating too much of it Heaven's Tossy
Heaven's to Betsy
I uh outside of the Chick-fil-A fry that
standard waffle fry nine times out of 10
in my entire life if I I like waffle
fries because to me they're identical to
curly fries they're not identical but if
I had to choose because they're because
let's just say the ones I I've seen and
ate are identical it's the same exact
it's the same um it's been the same um
uh uh what do you call it um come on man
but here's seasoning what I'm saying
seasoning and it's the same exact uh
batter crust on it exact but even if the
seasoning and Cur better but even if the
seasoning and battering are the same the
experience is different it's a different
type of FR you look you of all people
should know that you argued not even on
the show and we're going to do
shoestring today but you argue to me Sho
string is completely not traditional d d
d you shoestrings are seasoned the same
way regular r with salt usually they're
not season so my point is is you are
very aware
that the design of the fry plays into
this and that is a huge difference a
good point taking that's a good point
Tak so so a waffle fries design alone
whether it's seasoned or not is a is a
really special enjoyable and I like that
it's got little holes in it because it
gives it gives some air to the
experience it doesn't there's not a dens
this whereas your steak fry to me I feel
like I'm eating a log of potato okay too
much so yeah so I guess what I was
leaning into was every fry that's not
every fry that's seasoned the way a
regular fry is is original tasting
differently cut right you have all those
covered so when you said waffle fry I
just thought we checked the Box already
with curly fry but your point is it's a
good point here's the thing why I took
today I'm taking Sho string and I'm
taking steak okay because they are at
polar opposite ends of the fry Spectrum
if you got original traditional dead in
the- Middle right okay STI with steak
for now cuz that's the battle sure well
I'm just saying like well I love
shooring they no no no stick with steak
but I'm going to tell you why I show
steak so far in this battle you've
talked about Curly and now she was I'm
going to tell you why I like we never
started the timer by the way guys
this show is sponsored by better help we
love those folks over there I got to
tell you right now if you're thinking of
therapy if you've never tried it if
you're a vet I think you give this a try
it's online therapy made convenient and
easy just for you and I got to be honest
I was talking to who was I talking to my
my dad yesterday about how I think
therapy is should would be a good option
for him I'm trying to get him to try it
out because it's like going to the gym
uh for your mental state and I think
it's really really important and I
always feel because of my OCD and my
ADHD and my Hang-Ups that I get in my
own way I overthink everything and one
of the things that I found really help
me to process those things is therapy
because it's dedicated time that I spend
to talk about my thoughts out loud it
really kind of clears your mind and
clears the air and kind of freeze you up
when you didn't even know that could
happen so that's the way that I use it I
think if you're thinking of starting
therapy maybe you give better help a try
uh again it's flexible and suited to
your schedule you fill out a
questionnaire and they match you with a
licensed therapist and that's it you can
switch therapist at any time and there
is no additional charge make your brain
your friend with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com tastebuds toay you get
10% off your first month that's
betterhelp
hp.com buds folks who loves cereal we
love cereal especially here at the taste
buds podcast that's why we're proud to
have magic spoon as one of our sponsors
you know for the longest time as an
adult I couldn't eat cereal I could just
wasn't the best idea and that's why I'm
grateful for magic spoon coming along
and making a cereal experience a
childlike nostalgic cereal experience
accessible to somebody at my age why
because they took out all the bad stuff
magic spoon they've reinvented your
favorite childhood cereals to taste
great but each contains 0 g of sugar 13
to 14 g of protein and four to 5 net gr
of carbs per serving okay look it's also
ketofriendly it's glutenfree it's uh
grainfree it's soy free it's free of all
the free things it should be free of uh
and it's a great way to relieve those
moments when you're watching your
favorite cartoons yes I still do that
plus it's only 140 calories per serving
uh they've got a new product by the way
since we last saw magic spoon magic
spoon took the Magic in their cereal and
transformed it to an on the-go snack
they got a brand new treats it's called
treats and you can have totally
delicious high protein cereal bars for
breakfast dessert or anytime in between
uh these things are protein packed by
the way they're just like the
marshmallow treats you had as a kid but
with only one gram of sugar uh and one
to two grams of net carbs and again
they're packed with protein 11 gram per
bar my gosh almighty trust treats
comeing two flavors marshmallow and
chocolaty peanut
butter magic spoon's awesome anyway head
to
magpole of cereal and try the magic for
yourself and don't forget to add their
brand new marshmallow and chocolaty
peanut butter treats be sure to use our
promo code taste buds at checkout to
save $5 off your order Magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's backed
by 100% happiness guarantee so so if you
don't like it for any reason they will
refund your money no questions asked
remember get your next delicious bowl of
cereal at
magicpoint pimp why steak okay because
it's the polar opposite of what my
favorite is so it's a different
experience to me we're talking about the
cut of the fry right Sho string to me
you ever you ever eat um those Potato
Sticks you eat potato stick oh yeah I
used to love those as a kid cuz I feel
like I was getting like a I feel like I
was getting Adult food except that a
7-Eleven and you were getting a billion
I'm a huge fan of Potato Sticks as a
matter we should do them in a battle but
for me the shoe string fry is an
extension of potato STI Potato Sticks
and what I like is I like get them super
super crispy and crunchy and since
they're little
let I told you that I have a point
you're not even let me make it I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm just
afraid you're going to burn your juice
on Sho strings now no not now that's the
element that I love in that and when I
want something different than that the
way for me to go is the exact opposite
end of the spectrum the steak fry
essentially is basically like a little
basically like baked potato it's a it's
you get a different bite it's a
full-on piece of potato in a in a in a
bigger bigger bite it's it's although
it's although it's the same salted
potato it tastes and eats differently
right because it's a big substantial
chunk of potato it tastes differently in
your mouth it chews differently it dips
differently let me tell you what
nobody's ever done ever in the history
of fries yeah finished their steak fries
it's fine great it's too much that's
fine but you never love wanting you
never left wanting more too much there's
one time and one time only and it's not
even all the time yeah cuz a lot of time
in this situation I prefer the baked
potato but there's one time and one time
only I might enjoy a steak fry and it's
if I am at a steakhouse and I go old
school surf and
turf piece of steak piece of lobster
tail beautiful golden Cris steak fries
some what about a diner you might as
well call you you might as well call a
steak fry a diner fry what comes with
the Disco Fries when you put no that's
not true I get traditional fries usually
with with that stuff well from where I'm
from a disco fry or or Dino fry is a
steak fry and look I don't no no no no
no a disco fry is a dressing on the fry
you that that's not that's not true a
disco fry I've seen gravy fries a
million times with with regular 99% of
the time I see them on steak fries in
the diner that's a Disco Fries I mean
yeah brown gravy and whatever right so
my point though is that I don't always
love a steak fry but when I want
something different so basically take
the fry the regular traditional fry as
your constant well if I want a different
fry eating experience in that then I
have to either go one way or the other
way and I think the steak fry check the
box of well I'm going to be eating but
I'm going to be eating a fry today but
it's going to be almost like you're
really getting bites of actual potato
and texture of potato wherein as a
shoestring fry you're going to be
getting a crunch and it's not but tell
me why I fry is better than a waffle fry
you still haven't made your point I've
told you why a waffle fry is better than
I love everything I I love the
dimensions the shape the weight of it
the bite of it I like a I like a nice
steak fry I like I like the surface area
cuz you could spread ketchup on it
almost like you're spreading it on a
piece of bread and like get it nice and
and I and I like I like to take a bite
and really just if I'm in that mood
really feel like I'm eating a steak fry
a steak fry is so thick by the way less
fry a less like frying and more potato
experience by the way pimp Googled steak
fries bone appetite steak fries are
garbage right out of the gate steak
they're going at Ste oh those aren't
even that's even better those are steak
those are steak fries with skin still on
them I think think I love that go back
real quick please to that to these
pictures these pictures by the way are
not accurate pictures of steak fries oh
no we I was going to say truffle fry but
that's that's like that's on top these
fries are not steak fries these are
traditional fries steak fries are are
rectangular usually they're flat
yeah I look when I get steak fries nine
times out of 10 if I'm get a din Burger
I want a steak fry when I get a steak
fry I need no way dude that's crazy to
me but when I get a steak fry 19 of 10 I
need sour cream with it because I'm like
God damn man this just tastes like I'm
eating a baked potato every time I eat
the fry I mean no too much here what you
do you get a nice I like baked pot nice
golden brown because what what happens
with the steak fry is the outside can
have a nice little crisp when you bite
it but the inside is going to be nice
and moist and soft but that was your
argument again I I that was your
argument against the crinkle fry that's
what you said you didn't like about the
I I feel like crinkled fries taste Bland
and cheap the ones the frozen ones I
grew up with I just feel like it's well
the Frozen somehow a low quality potato
the frozen ones yeah but but we're you
know again we can't we can't Hing it all
on the Frozen I don't often see crinkle
outside of the frozen ones so that's
kind of was my experience but Del Taco
has an Inc their their only fries are
crinkle fries and they are incredible I
don't consider Nathan's a crinkle fry do
you I mean I know it's crinkled but it's
no no no no no but but now but then
you're going to have subsections right
you're going to have a traditional
crinkle and a thick cut steak crinkle
basically is what it is oh uh fair
enough all right we're all right listen
we're at time let's get the vote on this
I want to see what we got here I think a
steak fry is the second most classic fry
other than a traditional fry the Ste I
think that is true and I think it's for
a reason all right the steak fres is the
worst thing that ever happened to a
potato that's not true steak fries are
dried shove a potato up their ass steak
fries are dry and have no flavor the
sauce gets in the crevices of the waffle
fry great point I didn't think of that
the answer is waffle fries Aaron Rogers
eat steak fries and look how that worked
out waffle fries from Chick-fil-A
without a doubt uh steak fries are an
Abomination the worst thing the potato
since the Potato
Famine right underneath that the steak
fry is
Elite both Rock see they're going
Chick-fil-A on us they're attributing
the waffle fry to Chick-fil-A fry by the
way I'm surprised guys the the waffle
fry to Chick-fil-A is not good so your
credibility goes out the window if
that's what you think dude I think you I
I think you might be in for a pounding
here dude this ain't looking good this
isn't not looking good at all whoever
says Stak fries is at least 65 plus
years old knock that down 20 years
waffle fries are dry as F usually
crunchy too or they're crazy soggy so
I'm saying I'm assuming that's not I've
never had a I mean I said under crazy
soggy steak fry is Tater royalty too
many children voting for this waffle
nonsense nobody on this planet like
steak fries it's basically a quartered
potato with no crisp no my friend that's
a potato wedge and we didn't go there
steak fries is simply too much potato
steak fries are thick that's what you
want when you want potato all right this
guy says they're thick daddies and we
all need a little thickness in our
life uh steak fries always taste like a
stale potato
never had a fully cooked steak fry all
right take us take us to the vote I I
mean I'm getting demolished I'm going to
get demol all right we have 5,000 votes
come on where I Stak for people
at
pimpy all right 5200 votes pimp voted
for steak fry thank you but uh we took a
beating here WAFF 66% 6634 this is the
margin basically 2/3 to 1/3 that I think
most of our battles net out at bu in a
general sense I don't think today's
going to get any brighter for you in the
Second Battle because
you're to what are you nuts sh sho
string should have went up against
something else tater tot should should
sh sho string should have went up
against something else because Sho
string are not common and I don't think
people really are we in the battle for
Sho string now do it all right start the
clock pimp starts at 8 minutes thank you
sho string is the absolute if you don't
like a steak fry then you should have sh
string
on your neck because it's the exact OPP
strings are fine but but I said this to
you last week or whenever we talked and
texted about this I'm like
dude when you fully explained Sho string
to me I was like oh yeah okay they are
not commonly found they're amazing
though people I don't I don't know one
fast food place that has a shoe string
not one which is a which is a sign of
that these are not commonplace fries I
think they're more difficult to make I
really do are they yeah I mean In-N-Out
sort of does Sho strings but they're
In-N-Out Burgers got the worst fries on
planet Earth me real official
shooring yeah look buddy I know the fry
I'm saying like these are hard to come
by I will tell you what's a real treat
and I have had it look that right there
Bo I get it I have had I have you blanch
them yeah it's too much to yeah yeah I
have
had courtesy of someplace I don't
remember shoestring fries done as cheese
fries with the yellow whz
MH and it was pretty unreal because it
was like eating french fry spaghetti
yeah cuz you're getting like clumps of
these things with the cheese and
everything it was pretty awesome I like
I like a shoestring
fry cuz you can bundle them like sticks
yeah you can choose what you want and
really and really hit it hard but dude
the tater tot is the I mean my God Tater
tot's the tough one it's in an island of
its own and people you know people love
tater tots because they're not always
that common and they are for exactly
that they're different they're you talk
about a unique version of a fry that one
out of all of them is the one that is
the most unique cuz it's made
differently it's essentially a it's
essentially a it's it's not a it's not a
french fry if we're being honest you
almost didn't want to put I know you you
adamant about putting it in because I do
see it on menus at in in the same
capacity that a fry is used for if I see
a tater tot on a menu you're I'm I I
light up I'm like are you kidding me
that you guys have tater tot well that
speaks to my point it's like tater tots
if it's outside of a breakfast food you
don't see it that that that commonly and
so you're always going to go for it
there's not anyone that doesn't like a
tater tot and so I'm going to get my ass
hand it to me but what I submit is that
people aren't familiar enough with the
shoestring okay
for me out of every single cutter fry
even more than curly Sho string is the
most fun to eat it's the most tasty I I
just I like my fries extra I know where
you're getting Sho string fries like
where are you getting them I mean had
them my whole life I don't know where I
know but I'm saying like outside of
buying now we keep going back to how
Frozen freezer aisle is not ever the
best option for fries because you don't
have a deep fryer at home most people
don't my point is is outside of that o
section where the hell are you finding
chw string fries I I don't see them
anywhere well I mean but that's not
really part that doesn't really speak to
the battle I mean it doesn't the fact
that people aren't going to order them
and I'm going to I'm asking you in this
not in the sense of that's a strike
against it I'm asking you because you
love these things so much where the hell
are you eating them this frequently I
will tell you know what I noticed about
the sh Shing fry as well no I'm asking
yeah I I don't know I have them when
they around you know you got there's got
to be but I love them cuz I love an
extra crispy fry I also like to eat you
can eat 15 Cris uh sh string fries and
it's the equivalent of one steak you
know you're getting you're getting the
the bite at least over and over and over
but you're not killing yourself with it
you know what I mean I like that they're
light they don't get soggy I I just I
just I just love them I just like I just
love the way they bite I love I like
that I can put in a fistful or just one
I I just I just think when you dip them
they don't take on too much condiment
because they don't have enough surface
area to keep on there here's another
thing I think about I would disagree
with that I that I would disagree with
which I actually would say is a pro and
also a con of the Sho string I think
when you dip them they become drenched
in condiment because they're so
thin um no but they got that snap to it
but then but then but that's sometimes
what I like about a shoe string and
sometimes what I don't like I like my
Sho string to be halfway between a
french fry and a potato stick you
understand what I'm saying yeah you know
what I mean mean now here's what I like
about Sho string fries as well they're
never like on the menu when you have an
option like fries steak cut you know
sweet potato it never says shooring but
it's it's because it's considered
traditional in a way so just like when
it doesn't say like you know you're get
in a Ste cut a lot of times a place I
won't know they're doing Sho string
until the plate is dropped and I look
down and I go oh my God they do shoe
string like I didn't even I didn't have
the option it comes as a surprise they
chose that as a business
and when it hits my plate I'm just like
are you kidding me the Sho string fries
I'll always finish my Sho string fries
okay but I will say Tater Tot I don't
like had Sho string I don't like when
they're too crunchy I don't like that I
love that I don't like that
let no such thing as a very very very
crunchy Tater top no no no
that's crazy layer is a little snap to
it but that's the whole point of a t tot
it's not going to crunchy on theide
argue you just argue that steak fries
are like eating a whole goddamn potato
yeah what is a tater tot then even more
Den steak no no it's not the
circumference of a t to I can tell you
why it's not tater tots are hash browns
they're they're it's it's you have to
first create what goes in the middle and
then put it together and deep fry it's a
hash brown it's crispy Brown outside
crumbly flaky potato in the middle tater
tots and this is my Gauntlet throw this
is my how we doing on time for this
battle this is my gauntlet
throw for tater tot
together okay this is my Gauntlet throw
for tater tots tater tot is and I stand
by this the only thing in this battle
out of all the fries we have battled so
far the it is the only one where I do
not need a condiment ever I think Tater
tot's going into ketchup ruins the tater
tot I think it's a weird Clash it
doesn't taste good to me tater tot is is
it stands on its own and you eat tater
tot tater tot also are the only uh uh
fry uh U uh version of fry in this
battle that I think cons serve as its
own meal if you wanted it to if you
needed to eat if somebody said you got
to eat just potatoes for your meal today
steak fries or Disco Fries or curly
fries can do that I a bag of Tater TTS
I'm here's the thing about here's the
thing about tater tots okay at the end
of the day you pick that up it's got
some weight to it right they're like
these little freaking nuggets
right I'd say 30% or more of that weight
that heft in your hand is oil those
things absorb oil now the exact opposite
of a shoestring fry the Sho string fry
can only absorb so much oil that's it
it's done it's crisp it's cooked it's
done it's never going to be soggy that's
the whole point of a Sho string fry with
with tater tots even if you put take
them out and put them on a napkin or put
them in your hand you eat that thing you
look at your hand there's grease all
over your hand that grease is kind of
running through that Tater Tot and
that's why I can't finish a whole basket
of tater tots it's just it's too heavy
it's too weighted it gives you it can
give you like literally like a stomach
maybe you should need
a well the serving nobody says you have
to eat a whole basket the little little
tray thing those little paper trays that
they serve it in no dude you're that
that's you don't agree with me though
that that there could be a lot of oil
oil and grease inside of a tater tot
there could be a whole lot of oil and
grease in any version of a french fries
a tater tot though is is more than any
other name the fry that is more prone to
holding in oil than a tater I don't I I
I find quite the opposite I find often
when I get tater tots it is a very dry
uh thing on the outside there's not a
lot of oil I I know what you mean but no
usually my experience is not that
usually my experience with tat to is
that shell on the outside really
protects the inside you you you you eat
the first four or five Tates on top once
you get past that top layer of tater
tots that nucleus in the middle they're
all congealing they get squishing
together there's oil in there and then
they're all soggy after that
you're saying that about dud your shoe
strings turn into a basket of worms dude
what are we talking about no they don't
the Sho strings stay Crisp that's my
whole point if they're overdone I could
take a Sho string and go like this and
slice a tater tot in
half because I can I could use a strw
string as a sword because it's firm and
it's stiff and a t tot is just a mush
mushy blubber H together look let's go
to look like little dony Kong barrels
let's go to the phones let's go to the
phones time's up Sho string fries with
cheese dipping sauce will change your
life I agree calling a tater tot a fry
is like calling ketchup a
vegetable tater tots are not considered
French fries in the slightest but then
again Sho string fries are gross as hell
tater tots Sonic tater tots with cheese
are Sho string fries McDonald's fries
Sho string fries are flavorless limp
dick skinny fries they get cold they're
not limp that's the whole point though
you could have said they're flavorless
rock hard skinny fries I picked tater
tots over shoestring shoestring remind
me of Leather by the way I never said
this the name is the worst name of all
fries Sho Str I think it's fun oh God
yeah I want to think of shoelaces what
I'm eating uh I can't make tots you want
think of children no that's not what
tots how dare you I want uh uh yeah
Children of the future I want to think
of the future when I'm eating my lunch
when you're eating children now oh
that's not what I said you can make a
casserole out of you can't make a
casserole out of Sho string fries I
thought Sho string was only on my shoe
no it's also on fries Molly oh let me go
ahead and grab four Sho string fries at
once because it's the equivalent of one
regular french
fry out of here with that
noise that's so silly that's one of the
bonuses of it I love that uh I'm
convinced people only claim to like tots
because of Napoleon Dynamite oh that's
interesting it's hard to mess up a
tot uh Sho string fries are only good
when they're hot I feel like my
tater tots have the ability of being
their own dish thank you see all right
pimp let's go to the vote what do we got
what do we got what do we got 6,000
votes here think he's going to go with
tots Oh I thought I was going to lose
bigger than that I thought I was going
to lose it's it's nearly it's literally
nearly the same exact uh spread guys
drum roll here for the Humble Pie
segment you got tater tots after 6,029
votes winning with
63.2% to a sh strings 36.8 I'll tell you
what I think happened here I think the
wrong thing battled the wrong thing
today I think shoing would have went
further if it wasn't against the tot I
think the tot is going to find itself in
the finale possibly against the curly
fry well our semifinals now are the
curly fry yeah the traditional fry yes
the tater tot yes and the waffle fry
yeah problem is three of those are my
wins so you're now going to have to
battle for something that you fought
against previously yeah so we'll figure
that out we'll be back I guess probably
just the next not next week but the week
after next week will be a guest again
the week after that we'll we'll do the
yeah we'll wrap it we'll we'll we'll
well we'll do the semi-final and then
maybe the final together I don't know
we'll figure it out yeah we'll figure it
out all right guys I still love you
buddy love you too
babe the food they hate talking about
the food they like two fools going to
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man they coming to the